hi guys thank you
you heard back from your friend zoe
about um elizabeth banks agent
yeah um she
heard that they took out a restraining
order against you
but did she find that if elizabeth
remembered me the premise of this is
really funny
have you ever been in a scenario where
you were trying to convince people that
you knew somebody
like somebody famous i've had i've i had
a history of insecurity so i'm sure i
did that a couple times
i met shaquille o'neal once and i got a
picture with him holding me over his
head
like this and i can't find the picture
and
it's true but i don't believe you and
i'm playing luckily after digging
through the archives
sugarland actually found the photo
that's really fun you say that because i
actually have a picture with chucky
o'neil because we went to film school
together
well he came to my film school as a
special guest
and he directed me in one of his short
films and i took a picture with him and
i look
ridiculous next to him i'm co-chairing
our college reunion elizabeth banks is
invited what if she shows up
you won't be able to go unless you can
test the restraining order and when i
think even the layman goes
if you don't stop you may not be a
layman for a long time
so how much would it be if to fight it
i'd bill at 7.50 an hour
i'm 800. wow that's a lot
you couldn't resolve it in half an hour
could you
no sorry good luck
his college reunion is coming up and so
he gets on social media for the first
time he's never had a facebook account
he gets on social media he doesn't know
what he's doing i
personally also still have no idea what
i'm doing with social media
um but he kind of he kind of attempts to
do that and then in the discovery he
remembers that elizabeth banks
the actress was a part of his college
class
and so he starts sending all of these
messages to her
just to say hi and can't stop and
doesn't realize that his messages are
public
how much do you charge by the hour my
rate
is 85
dollars an hour perfect
was there a moment when you were
together or you were filming a scene or
there's one line where you just kind of
went oh this is clicking like i know
this is going to work
what if we all were like can't think of
one time
i don't think there was one time that it
actually joked
i remember one of the first few couple
days when i knew it was going to click
was when tony and
paul walter house were improvising and
at one point he put a staple through his
hand
is that what you want do you want me to
put a staple through my hand
i'll do it where he was like i can't cut
around you laughing like we have like
i'm actually breaking
and he's like i don't know how to cut
around you totally ruining the shot and
i was like
i didn't think this was real there's no
question the film is filled with
unexpected moments
and there are even more great stars
including alicia cuthbert robbie mel and
sarah choc
yes director scott abramovic brought out
the best in canadian talent
this is the kind of story i think that
people are hoping to find right now
something that makes you feel good
optimistic and i think that you know
sid's journey kind of represents
a little bit of ourselves trying to find
our way back to human connection right
now